I think she has average Gamers
face that way do the squad face I'm just
kidding you just said Nina's mom watches
this you're [ __ ] disgusting person
you're so comfortable I feel exploited I
think I'm gonna leave
out that door though all right
[Music]
does anybody here know somebody who is
insecure about their shortness and
height
I know Bart's confident right now but
who do you know me yeah me you're
insecure about your height and your
shortness in it yeah why
I'm not allowed to no
how tall are you because you're a tough
dude that's not it doesn't count I don't
I don't look at you and think to myself
that you're even short one one minute oh
I think it's because it's uh perspective
do you think I'm short you know what I
mean I think you're shorter than Bart
we're about the same height how tall are
you okay can you guys both cry real
quick yeah it's five eight compare five
nine I'm trying to cry about right five
eight five nine five eight five seven
dude okay who do you know who do you
know Nick is it you yeah so you're
insecure about your head as well I'm not
like that it's a girl but I wish I was
taller sometimes yeah you're not short
no you fall short of expectation but
you're not sure
plus you're on the ground most of the
time [ __ ] Jujitsu nah dude I wish I
was taller a little bit like I was
trying to grab Ranch I don't really like
uh partake in any exactly that'd be time
for grab it yeah but like I don't
partake in any like plastic surgery or
anything like that I'll break my music
if they had a um a safe surgical
procedure to add a few inches how tall
would you want to be what's your dream
height
your dream height
if it was whatever no strings attached
with the blue costume
you know you gotta break your knees he
wears off at midnight
strikes 12 it turns into pumpkin me
shoes gotta be this big it's like the
East Bay jumper shoes that [ __ ]
because that is that is the thing right
where like you spend 20 30 years
whatever learning this body like your
brain's learning it so the minute you
add like let's say two inches to your
calf bone or something you have to kind
of relearn and reprogram how to run so
that's the part that's like you could be
anatomically more advantageous but uh
brain oily
[Laughter]
oh sorry I don't know anyone that's uh
well I'm not insecure about my high but
I do know some guys that are I'm not
gonna say who but it's either Justice or
[ __ ] hoyan no that is my only two
friends dude they're both like five ten
or five eleven yeah they're taller than
me for sure but like I do know people
that like wear shoes that have thicker
soles like guys specifically to appear
taller
no would you say these are would you say
these are thick soles no no like
straight up like they would wear boots
like platforms don't say my [ __ ] name
can when you wear tins though
you do go like oh yeah so so when you
look at guys that wear boots like maybe
they might be insecure about their
height so they're just wearing it so
it's just appear a little taller you
know yeah or maybe they like boots cam
Maybe
could be both so a doctor shares what
happens when men get height lengthening
surgery
give it to me are you guys familiar with
Highlander which part lengthens we'll
get into that right top of your head
isn't the surgery like this like they
they break it they go
and they put like a spacer in oh God
I'm gonna extendo
this is uh you guys can't really see
right here but that long thing it's this
nail will be implanted in the patient's
femurs to permanently make him three
inches taller right here that's the one
whoa you think you could spot as much
there's got to be complications like
this can't be and the time that it's
gonna take to recover and to adapt
strength wise the longer your femurs the
weaker your squat the more anatomically
disadvantaged towards squat so like when
you have a short femur uh you can squat
way more and then um you can squat more
upright so that's the thing where it's
like sometimes you think you're solving
a problem and that's why I was so
curious about it let's see our femurs
let's let's uh compare our femurs that
is relative too it's relative to your
hip mobility my waist is right here Bart
it's relative to your hip mobility and
uh and your and your bottom half to him
see now let's see your score what the
heck we have the same you could be you
could right but look at this height
compared to mine yeah yeah
let me see a squat
they're probably average Gamers average
yeah what about us my boy
oh you just have insane Mobility so
usually usually like when your femurs
are long right what happens is like when
they squat they go up to a more good
morning position like this versus like
within his Mobility is so good like his
knees just travel forward oh because
he's got the Asian Squad going on so
he's all right he's got them right here
yeah yeah yeah yeah what about your
femurs you got you got some femurs girl
yo she got some fiends dude Colleen's
got some fiends yep
are those long femurs wait let's see
your squash he's got the boots on too
though I think she has average streamers
that way do the squad you're gonna face
I'm just kidding
you just said Nina's mom watches this
you're [ __ ] disgusting person
you know I don't feel comfortable Put
the gun down I think I'm Gonna Leave
can stop okay we need you hey just leave
out that door guys
[Music]
take your long females yeah I'm out of
here guys
your mom's gonna wonder what kind of
news show this is again
when you're just driving the way of the
chair
when do you guys cover the weather what
that's my mom never are you ever are you
ever too secure about your height that
you have so much of it two ceiling yeah
do you ever catch yourself getting a
little cocky uh I'm I'm 5 12. so uh for
real six six perfectly man that's nice
congrats bro because you're like always
pick up the litter like when you [ __ ]
hang out with other Asians they just go
this guy
okay first of all
it's all relative right it's all about
who you grow up with or who you hang out
with so like like Bart said it's all
perspective I have a lot of cousins that
are short so I always thought I was
freakishly tall and long in an insecure
oh go [ __ ] yourself oh sorry you want to
talk about your big dick next you go you
go in the room and they're like hey guys
I'm so insecure
this room's really suffocating you know
that it's like it sucks to be a ball
look how tall he is dude
I can't handle this dude
get your ass back over here man yeah he
just wanted to stand up as you can see
his height full scale the views are
going up we're getting up yeah wow what
do you mean you're insecure about that's
[ __ ] weird that's lame bro because
it's not like you got dealt a very rare
and good card I don't even know why I'm
being attacked right now if you're six
six because you're six foot being
worshiped as usual yeah that's like
being insecure because you're a
millionaire yeah are you interested
about that too [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I
didn't get a chance to buy four houses
yet one at a time he doesn't have a mom
over time yeah he can fit through the
doorway nothing like you yeah yeah you
freak you're freak shut the [ __ ] up so
this it really hurts my feelings so this
doctor he posts this stuff on Tick Tock
so people are finally kind of getting
exposed to even understanding that uh
heightening is a surgery that some
people do for Aesthetics right and this
one guy comments on there too he said uh
he wanted to take the opportunity to
make sure that people are properly
considering truly what the surgery does
which is actually kind of on the tip
that Bart was sharing he says before
y'all even do it think they can they
can't stretch your nerves are you gonna
lengthen your arms to match your new
proportions think about that when you're
old so just kind of the idea like I said
you're you're already disproportionate
that's the thing sometimes your arm's
already long exactly exactly you're
really broad shoulder the type of people
that this kind of surgery makes sense
for is to more balance out some of your
proportions maybe you are already born
with some sort of like deficiency in
your femurs or just like a you know
naturally why'd you look at me
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
like how many people uh knew that the
this lengthening procedure was kind of
becoming more popular I didn't even know
it was a real thing I knew it was a
thing I didn't know was becoming popular
yeah I thought it was [ __ ] a
fictional thing for the movie Gattaca
yeah see where they break his legs don't
they yeah you remember that they break
his legs and he grows taller they
[ __ ]
and they're doing the whole surgery like
that and I was like is that how [ __ ]
people do this
but you know I I didn't honestly think
about the implications of somebody like
changing their the brainiology like you
said do you think there's a cover-up
because you know like when people get
nose jobs and they don't want to say
they got a nose job they say they had to
accept a [ __ ] what's the thing
deviated septum and they always go oh
idea is that I had to fix it oh it looks
so gorgeous on accident but like I
wonder if there's a cover-up for this
we're like there's a go-to oh you know
what you're gonna get the high thing but
just tell everybody that you [ __ ] I
don't know tell them you got a BBF
double ACL tear or some [ __ ] or you go
like I I was just slouching before you
know so finally went to a chiropractor
yeah yeah yeah posture a posture problem
got my spine lengthened because every
every cosmetic or like thing has a
medical thing to pair with it so that
you don't get made fun like you didn't
know but I had severe scoliosis in my
spine
um yeah or you could just own it and
just be like I'm taller now I got
surgery because I wanted to be tall and
then that's like you going around age
like 40 being like I drank milk
yesterday yeah what's wrong with that
would you guys notice if like someone a
friend of yours was five eight and then
suddenly was five eleven no I would have
noticed yeah that's a substantial amount
that's a lot especially at that cusp 5'8
is because when you're like like let's
say someone's like he goes from five
three to five five probably not really
or someone's like six two to six five
but right at that cusp is where like I
think you notice big time because most
people around five seven five eight I
think most of the time you know that's
the average I think so yeah I feel like
you're going from like uh dudes like us
little guys like us yeah if I was yeah I
think if I was like five three as a dude
I could shoot yourself off like trying
to get it
this would be worth living he's like I
guess I'll just jumps five three I'd be
a break dancer if you know what I mean
oh dang like b-boy pocket yeah dude the
physics of that is like crazy you better
do something with that height
grab Rim how tall are the people on
choreo cookies
nah the video was gonna end already
[Laughter]
[Music]